to my future president my name is
Monique verda I am a daughter of the
United holman nation a citizen of south
Louisiana I live near the mouth of the
mississippi river where the Gulf of
Mexico meets the Delta just south of
cancer alley just north of the dead zone
we are experiencing unprecedented loss
from our shores as the tides rise and
the land subsides our communities have
some of the worst air quality in the
nation we've got oil waste pets in our
backyards the houma my nation have one
of the oldest relationships with the
federal government it goes back over 200
years back to 1803 when America
purchased the Louisiana territory and
since then we've been petitioning the
federal government for land and water
rights my ancestors dodge the Trail of
Tears by finding refuge in the Delta but
our old settlements are now being
sacrificed to the sea our oak trees are
dying their roots burned by salt waters
our burial grounds are being submerged
and our traditional medicinal plants are
becoming harder and harder to find the
Mississippi River Delta is a power point
for the planet it is an estuary a
sanctuary rich in resources in
biodiversity one of the world's wombs
the Gulf South helped build our nation
and in turn we have been forced to make
the ultimate sacrifices we are suffering
and enduring the consequences Hurricane
Katrina's tidal surge filled our houses
with water the BP drilling disaster
forced our fishermen to be hazardous
material cleanup workers federal
policies have misguided our coastal
communities into a state of crisis
forcing us to debate if restoration as
possible or if now is the time to
retreat
we're living on the front lines bearing
witness to a changing climate but we
know we're not the only ones and if we
don't begin to change our ways there
will only be more to come